[Música]
las tropas rusas siguen su ofensiva
hacia kiev pero no logran avanzar ante
la eficacia del ejército ucraniano moscú
tiene cerca de 5 ciudades dejando a
miles de personas atrapadas sin agua
comida electricidad ni medicinas
en la cumbre de versace estos líderes de
la unión europea rechazaron el pedido de
ucrania de una rápida adhesión al bloque
mientras que rusia convocó a el consejo
de seguridad de la onu por las supuestas
actividades químicas en militares de
excelencia que según el kremlin de
financia washington
y nuestra enviada especial a ucrania
visitó el oeste del país donde llegan
desplazados de las zonas bajo fuego nos
trae la historia de una red de
psicólogos que atienden a las víctimas
en su mayoría mujeres y niños pero
también voluntarios que se preparan para
ir a la guerra
un cordial saludo aquí están las
noticias de france 24 y actualizamos el
avance de las tropas rusas en territorio
ucraniano
las fuerzas del kremlin cierran el cerco
sobre kiev hay más probabilidades de una
confrontación terrestre a medida que los
locales defienden la capital mientras
allí se concentra el esfuerzo bélico hay
estancamiento del avance de sobre harkov
y tampoco hubo muchos cambios en sap
orilla ni en mykolaiv sin embargo esta
es el último obstáculo para que moscú se
apodere de o deza y controle toda la
salida al mar negro el presidente
ucraniano volodymyr selenski rechazó la
acusación de rusia de laboratorios de
armas químicas en su territorio
financiados supuestamente por eeuu
mientras que rusia convocó para este
viernes una reunión del consejo de
seguridad por las que llamó actividades
militares e biológicas
siempre
donde atacarán con armas químicas en el
hospital de maternidad de mariupol en la
iglesia de hardcore en el hospital
infantil o madrid
magnet 1000 y modo moratoria o en los
laboratorios la mayoría desde la época
soviética y se dedican a la ciencia
ordinaria no tecnología militar
somos personas decentes soy el
presidente de un país decente una nación
decente y el padre de dos hijos
y no se desarrollaron armas químicas ni
otras armas de destrucción masiva en mi
tierra todo el mundo lo sabe ustedes lo
saben wii y si hacen algo así en contra
de nosotros obtendrán la respuesta de
sanciones más severas si estáis ya ese
samsung de adrián los movimientos
diplomáticos continúan desde varios
frentes en francia los líderes de la
unión europea rechazaron la posibilidad
de una adhesión rápida de ucrania al
bloque mientras que eeuu aprobó un
millonario plan de asistencia por casi
14.000 millones de dólares para los
ucranianos
entretanto rusia y hablaron en turquía
sobre la situación humanitaria de las
principales ciudades bajo ataque ruso y
washington avanzó en su relación con
países suramericanos convirtiendo a
colombia en su mayor aliado no miembro
de la otan y estrechando los lazos con
venezuela después de años de sanciones a
ese país informe de juan pabló de lo
cómico
tiembla al plano geopolítico el
canciller ruso se reunió en la ciudad
turca de antalya con la vicepresidenta
de venezuela del xiv rodríguez y aunque
no trascendieron detalles del encuentro
éste se da después de que una delegación
estadounidense viajará a caracas en
busca de acuerdos energéticos con el
país que ha sancionado por años este
encuentro de bercy rodríguez con lávrov
va un poco en la línea de poder
informarle de cuál fue la intención de
lo que se habló allí en miraflores
además de eso seguramente de avalar y
darlo a espaldarazo a rusia y por
supuesto recordar que en rusia hay
capitales de venezuela tanto las
instituciones como por ejemplo pedevesa
como también de particulares vinculados
al gobierno de nicolás maduro entretanto
el vecino de venezuela colombia fue
designado por el presidente de estados
unidos como el mayor aliado no miembro
de la otan un estatus especial que
contra de privilegios económicos y
militares que tan sólo ostentan 17
países en el mundo bueno esto es un
espaldarazo que le da al gobierno
colombia
y una forma de tratar de dar un mensaje
a venezuela de que está en la zona de
que eeuu no está descuidando su patio
trasero y que tiene un aliado muy
importante como lo es colombia pero
bueno eso eso más allá de cambiar un
poco la la tónica y la intención del
acercamiento de washington a venezuela
no lo cambia sin embargo la acción de
eeuu podría ser una movida que impulse a
colombia a reconocer el gobierno de
nicolás maduro con quien ha tenido
diferencias durante años mientras tanto
en el oeste de ucrania se han creado
decenas de redes de apoyo para quienes
huyen de las zonas atacadas y
bombardeadas por el ejército ruso
un grupo de psicólogas en la ciudad de
dehiba no franks viste se han dedicado a
arropar a quienes llegan aterrorizados
por los tanques y los bombardeos esto
incluye a mujeres y niños pero también
voluntarios que se preparan para ir a la
guerra reporte de nuestra enviada
especial de catalina gómez ángel
colegios como estos se han convertido en
el punto de encuentro de miles de
desplazados que llegan a estas de iván o
franco y la comunidad se ha organizado
para darles ropa cobijas juguetes para
los niños alimentos la mayoría de esas
personas tuvieron que huir de sus
ciudades apenas con lo puesto y también
vienen bastante traumatizados hay una
red de más de 100 psicólogos dispuestos
a ayudarlos a que inscriban su nombre y
nos remiten a un lugar especial
hablamos con quienes llegan sobre esos
miedos los apoyamos y les ayudamos no a
quitarse el temor sino a comprenderlo y
aceptarlo y quitarse de esta situación
es imposible pero saber cómo comportarse
apropiadamente es muy importante en 606
y reservar la guerra en la región de
donbass en 2014 ya había creado redes de
apoyo de psicólogas que daban soporte no
solamente a los desplazados sino también
a los soldados que pelearon allí y han
vuelto a reactivarse incluso con
psicólogas que llegan de ciudades que
están siendo atacadas
necesito trabajar porque me gusta mucho
mi profesión me gusta trabajar con niños
y adolescentes conocí la gente de este
centro y por eso he venido he traído los
juguetes y estamos listos para esperar a
los niños que vienen con sus mamás desde
kiev archiv para ayudarlos a relajarse y
demás jarkko va de todos modos
también trabajamos con soldados de la
defensa territorial donde intentamos
enseñarles unos ejercicios prácticos que
les servirán para entender sus
reacciones y cómo tienen que comportarse
negocios tras esta red de psicólogos se
distribuye durante el día en la estación
de tren por ejemplo en colegios donde
acogen a a estos desplazados y como inés
por ejemplo así por órganos dice que si
bien muchos piden ayuda psicológica lo
que primero necesitan es arreglar sus
problemas esenciales que es por ejemplo
encontrar donde vivir que comer y qué
hacer mientras se acaba la guerra por lo
menos en las próximas semanas mientras
que tienen alguna noticia
francia ha acogido a más de 7.000
refugiados ucranianos hasta ahora y se
prepara para recibir muchos más en los
próximos días en la estación de tren de
este de parís la cruz roja se ha
movilizado para acoger y ayudar a las
familias que llegan informe de gabriel
cocha
francia ha acogido a cerca de 7000 de
los más de 2 millones de ucranianos
desplazados por la guerra según las
autoridades de parís los refugiados
podrían llegar a ser entre 50.000 y
100.000 en las próximas semanas en este
momento tenemos unos cuantos miles de
personas que están presentes en el suelo
francés se pretende que algunos de ellos
puedan beneficiarse del régimen de
protección temporal creado al nivel
europeo que les permite permanecer en
suelo francés y beneficiarse de la
protección de un acceso con derecho al
trabajo en particular en la estación
este de parís la cruz roja se ha
movilizado para acoger a las familias
ucranianas que llegan e indicarles dónde
ir algunos sólo están en tránsito para
llegar a otros países europeos mientras
otros pretenden quedarse en francés
y dónde está
antigua en mi país viviera no de esa ya
pasamos por moldavia rumanía eslovaquia
polonia alemania y ahora estamos en
francia porque tenemos familiares en
este país
250 niños ya están inscritos en las
escuelas francesas como en niza donde
algunos integraron las clases de la
escuela jun 6 andrei con siete años
junio de kiev con su madre y llegó este
martes a la ciudad del sur de francia
pero se adapta rápidamente
y los niños lo acepta muy bien para él
no fue muy complicado tenía miedo de ir
a la escuela porque no habla francés
pero todo el mundo es amable la
profesora es muy simpática y los alumnos
lo ayudan a adaptarse
el objetivo es que vuelvan a la vida de
niños y de tumen poco a poco sus clases
síganos en france 24 y en france 24
punto com para más actualizaciones sobre
la guerra en ucrania
[Música]